the starting pitcher stats are brought
to you by home furniture we look at matt
shoemaker's
stats as he gets ready to toe the hill
for the for the twins
one and two to l'oreal
a strikeout
good start as shoemaker strikes out
l'oreal
and mitch it's a drive left center field
up the alley for a base hit might be
extra bases a rise over to left center
to field it fires into second there's a
relay throw and it's not in time and
moreland has a two base hit with one out
in the first
and to kepler again
and that enzo scores
moreland kept in the ballpark and it's a
scoreless top of the first frankie
montas on the mound for the oakland
hayes tonight and his starting pitcher
stats are brought to you by home
furniture you're
you're looking at him there as dick
mentioned
he had struggled in april a little bit
his pitch
much better up late
so we can gonna miss 95 miles an hour
foul tip
donaldson strikes out
high in the air toward right field
toward the line
the scotty is under and he's got it and
that will do it so lead off manafort but
nothing else no score after one for
minneapolis
driven to center deep center field
kepler going back and making the catch
at the fence
a great running catch right at the wall
by max kepler
max the catch up against the bullpen
fence in left center field
[Applause]
a running catch right near the 411 sign
for max oriano struck out to open up the
game lorianno did he get it and that
baby's gone second deck
so ramon lauriano gives the a's a
one-nothing lead with a long home run
[Applause]
again trying nice diving stop by polanco
and he throws him out
the stop was one thing
but he got back up so quickly and threw
him out
[Music]
i said way back in the beginning of the
year when they were they got simmons
that are going to move
to play shortstop that jorge was going
to be a gold glove caliber second
baseman and he was going to be a
terrific defensive player
get another chance
pretty much the same play from the
outfield grass
how about that
going to his right once in the dirt
and in the very next at bat the same
play in the grass
murphy has good power and murphy waits
here it is and a breaking ball is a high
fly ball left field back on it a rise he
will turn and watch it fly and murphy
has hit a two-run home run and the
athletics have taken a three-nothing
lead
biscotti waits and he swings and drives
one left field arise going back on this
deep in the alley looking up and he'll
watch that one fly
the third home run for the ace tonight
and that's a two-run blast by biscotti
and the a's take a five-nothing lead
one-on-one
lead off man here in the six twins need
to answer somehow get a run down and
there's
the drive to left by thousand and
there's euro
there's your answer
fourth home run of the year for josh
donaldson and the twins are on the board
[Music]
larnica left-handed hitter the local kid
it's a ground ball to first back of the
bag olsen flipping bone toss covering
for the out inning over
twins on the board on the home run by
donaldson after six it's five to one
athletics
doink down the right field line
and it's a fair ball and it rolls away
from the right fielder biscotti
and ostidio
clapping his hands twice one for each
base
[Music]
and into right field of base head
ostidial will be held might have cost
kepler a bat he'll consider it a good
exchange
home run
and it's six to one well that fan bought
their tickets and said hey
can i get a souvenir sitting here
and mark kenneth said oh absolutely
so four home runs for the a's tonight
1-1 pitch a fly ball left center field
deep in the alley kepler over to his
right on the track max jumps up makes
the catch at the wall
route number three piscotti missed his
second homer by a few feet but the a's
at one
rise deep and left kepler straight away
in center larnica stepper two in and
right
and the two two swag and a miss and down
he goes
on a curveball at 72 ostedio did throw
quickly up the first base line but
pinder not going anywhere
lost system toward right center that's
gonna get down for a hit
pender's going to head over to third so
nice job of hitting by elvis sanders
[Applause]
need to make some noise in the bottom
starting with trevor learning and this
is an outing i would imagine for bob
melvin where he's just trying to get
trevino out there and have a good outing
catcher always hustles to first base to
get the pitcher out of the way so he's
not involved here's osteo hitting a
drive in the right center field
piscotty's going to get there and he
makes the catch he quickly two away in
the ninth
kepler takes a walk so four played
appearances
he's reached three times
[Music]
pop-up
and this should do it
elvis anders out in shallow center field
he grabs it and that is the ball game
[Music]
so the a's use the long ball as they
take game one of the series get frankie
montos his fifth win of the year four
home runs
for the athletics
the heroes were lorianno murphy biscotti
and canada
time of game was three hours and two
minutes from minnesota and the final
score tonight the athletic six and the
minnesota twins won